best questions a screenwriter can ask
themselves to develop a better story
right up front is what is the story what
is the movie story or what is the TV
story that's where the logline comes in
that everybody is so happy to talk about
but it really is a one-sentence
expression of your intention if you
can't get that down you might want to go
back in and and really rien you know is
there something to write here so first
of all ask yourself what is that one
sentence expression once you have that
then you want to ask yourself you know
what turns you on about that idea okay
based on what excites you about that
idea now ask well what are the scenes
that express that excitement you know
that really really show those beats that
are that you have to show on screen you
know and then keep working backwards
from there okay who are the people that
populate that scene what do they say so
if you start big picture and then you
keep sort of breaking it down to the
things that excite you the people in it
what they say I think I think those are
the questions to ask you as you're
writing
you